hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 11
video we get to meet a couple new
characters so I'll try to explain who
they are some people from the comics
some people not from the comics the back
after the season is going to slowly
introduce the idea of Inhumans to the
Marvel Universe which is a really big
deal it's huge that Marvel is letting
their TV division introduce this but the
movies so far away they probably just
didn't want to wait so I'm just gonna
start with an explainer for who some of
these new characters are so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet starting with this guy right
here the reader
he's only appeared in the more recent
comics but he has the ability to make
whatever he wants to real so it seems
like his TV version is gonna be a little
bit different from the comic book
version right now the only powers we've
seen a manifest or teleportation that
might be the extent of his powers in the
TV show sometimes whenever they take
characters out of the comics they'll
simplify their powers just because
they'll either be too outlandish or too
ridiculous are too expensive to do on
screen so unless we get some different
information I'm just gonna call this guy
a D powered version of the reader the
other really big character was one of
the heads of Hydra the Baroness in the
comics she's the wife of the younger
Baron Zemo the the most recent Baron
Zemo I know it gets a little confusing
but Erin's emo is a title that just gets
passed down from father to son there's a
lot of rumors that we might see Baron
Zemo and Captain America Civil War but
don't expect to see him on the TV show
it seemed like most of them were taken
out by the end of the episode so I'm not
expecting to see a whole lot from her in
the future that was a pretty badass way
to end the episode
high fives to Coulson so let's just go
ahead and get started with top five
moments starting with number five
Inhumans flashback we get to see Skye's
mother again and learn a little bit
about what her role was inside the in
human society as far as we know they're
only a single group of people there I
mean there could be pockets of them all
over the earth but this character is
just a younger version of the reader the
character that shows up at the end of
the episode to save Raina the last time
we saw Skye's mother she didn't have
much of a speaking part but the way they
show her off here makes it seem like she
was actually really important like she'd
been around for a long time and had been
helping induct new members into their
society that means they probably have
more crystals on reserve if they're able
to pick and choose who they introduced
to the mists I like the Star Wars vibe
that it gave off to like he is young
enough to accept the training to learn
new things he'll be able to adjust it
makes me wonder
they're gonna create anymore new
inhumans this season I'm not expecting
them to just because it seems like now
they're gonna be dealing with rain and
sky developing their powers and learning
about the society so one thing at a time
but the doors open and they're not gonna
close it so there will be more new
inhumans eventually moving on to number
4 meet the heads of Hydra the biggest
name drops here Bravo obviously Baron
von Strucker who we know is gonna be an
age of Ultron and the Baroness for the
most part they're all gone but if you
remember the end of Winter Soldier I was
actually just re watching it the other
night Baron von Strucker at the end of
that says we'll feed them the other
Hydra cells to keep them off our scent
like Baron von Strucker doesn't give a
crap about the rest of Hydra he just
wants to continue his experiments with
the mind gem I'll be really interested
to see if they try and tide the mind gem
like Quicksilver or Scarlet Witch
Baron von strucker's experiments to the
Inhumans and their powers but as of
right now like in the comics they're
definitely very separate things the
movies tend to simplify things a lot so
I don't know how they'll explain that
logic so we'll just have to wait for age
of Ultron to come out onto number 3
Coulson puts on a stage play to get the
heads of Hydra to take themselves out I
vaguely recall Coulson or someone else
making a joke about Hydra biting its own
heads off last year I don't know if that
actually happened but in my head I feel
like it did that's basically what they
did perfectly pulled off I mean the
pacing in this episode was great and
this plan is the best example of that
moving on to number two arena is super
pissed what have we become I was
surprised at how mad she was now part of
me thinks that she's gonna try and turn
that group of in humans against Skye I
explained it a little bit at the end of
the Inhumans video that I posted earlier
today but Raina and Skye are like two
sides of the same coin Raina has been
running towards her heritage her whole
life this guy's been running away they
both found it but in a cruel twist of
fate Raina did not get exactly what she
wanted like her wish was granted in a
very evil way which is why that last
scene was really important because the
reader who rescued her says hello
beautiful
so I think not only is that the birth of
a new ship the rest of the season for
her will be learning to embrace her new
appearance it's the same thing with
mystique and her appearance it's about
learning to be comfortable in your own
skin so to speak
I will be really interested to see if
Raina tries to go after Skye because as
she said she feels Skye took
what was rightfully hers her birthright
although that's not how terrigenesis
works whenever Inhumans undergo
terrigenesis it just unlocks their
genetic potential so Raina was always
going to look like that it had nothing
to do with Skye being there there's no
definitive explanation as to why some
people undergo physical transformations
and why some people look the same part
of the reason I think is because comic
book writers and concrete book artists
just want people that look really badass
but another side effect is is that
sometimes when a mutant like an x-men
mutant for example like Quicksilver
undergoes terrigenesis it will make the
powers that they already have much more
powerful or very unpredictable so if
someone already had superpowers and they
took in the myths and they they had the
inhuman gene they might just get really
crazy versions of the powers they
already have I don't think they're gonna
deal with that too much just because it
feels like it would unnecessarily
complicate the plotline and they're just
now introducing the idea of what
Inhumans are speaking of which my number
one WTF moment Hail Marys save by the
reader
so rewind all the way back to the
midseason finale he was the guy in the
post-credits sequence when the Terrigen
crystal went off that activated Raina
and Skye's powers it signaled another
one wherever he was wherever their
little community is based on the way his
powers work I'm guessing that whenever a
new inhuman manifests and they're like
the little crystal alarm goes off it's
his job to go out and grab them and
bring them into the fold this is where
things get really interesting because I
think that their group is gonna be
relatively neutral it'll be like the
Inhumans in the comics relative to the
Avengers and the other teams so for
instance Black Bolt with the Illuminati
fights with the Avengers but that
doesn't mean that all of the Inhumans
are totally in love with everyone else
on earth
there's a lot of parallels now between
this show and Avengers age of Ultron
because we haven't met Scarlet Witch or
Quicksilver I mean obviously The
Avengers will meet them for the first
time in the movie but it will not be a
very friendly first meeting so I think
the same situation will go down on the
show like the first time team Coulson
meets team Inhumans there'll be a small
fight but they're not a bad group of
people so eventually they'll probably
reconcile and fight whoever the big
villain turns out to be the back half of
the season they claim Whitehall is dead
but we didn't see his body burned and he
has a healing factor so I'm expecting
him to resurface at some point part of
me kind of hopes that he took in the
mists but I think he already has his
inhuman power
because he stole him from Skye's mom
edward james olmos is gonna be a really
big character but I don't think that
he's going to be the big villain but
Hydra Baron von Strucker still very much
present in this universe here's my big
question for you guys who do you think
that the big villain is gonna be for the
second half of the season do you think
that Whitehall is gonna come back you
know with like crazy inhuman powers or
do you think that rain is just gonna go
nuts I know I didn't mention it but
there's the whole mockingbird Mac plot
with like the little mini RC version of
Lola's they said they were looking for
Fury's toolbox that's the little black
box that Nick Fury gave Coulson last
season it's a massive hard drive of
Secrets so no idea what they're using it
for but I don't think they're Hydra
they're not evil but until we learn more
most of my focus is gonna be on the
Inhumans stuff I think by the end of the
season you know whatever their side plot
is it'll it'll tie back to the Inhumans
but for now they're two completely
separate things so most of our attention
should just be on Skye and Raina and
what's going on with them you should
also be really excited because stuff on
the TV show will slowly lead up into
what's going on in age of Ultron I mean
it'll be a softer crossover than Winter
Soldier just because shield isn't as big
a deal in the age of Ultron universe the
producers did confirm though that the
ramifications of age of Ultron won't be
as earth-shattering is the ramifications
of Winter Soldier
just because shield came crashing down
in that movie I think I already
mentioned it in my my Inhumans video
earlier today but there's a new age of
Ultron trailer new Avengers trailer
coming on Thursday be sure to subscribe
to get that I'll post my breakdown after
it drops but I'm also probably gonna do
a bonus video for age of Ultron two so
if you have any special requests leave
them now while you guys wait for that
stuff you can click here for a refresher
on the origin story the Inhumans in the
comics and you can click here for all my
age of Ultron videos thank you so much
watching let's all high five I'll see
you guys tomorrow let's do the thing
you